la candidatura oficialista la
presidencia Argentina tiene nombre Unión
por la patria la nueva denominación de
la coalición anteriormente conocida como
frente de todos nombró a sus
representantes de Cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del próximo 22 de octubre
por responsabilidad institucional
política y social nuestro espacio ha
decidido conformar una lista de unidad
que nos representará en las próximas
elecciones el ministro de economía
Sergio massa acompañado por el jefe de
gabinete Agustín Rossi como aspirante a
la vicepresidencia buscarán la jefatura
de la casa rosada el anuncio se conoció
a poco más de 24 horas del cierre del
plazo para oficializar las candidaturas
de Cara a las primarias abiertas
simultáneas y obligatorias conocidas
como paso en la carrera por el cupo
peronista quedaron por fuera personajes
cercanos a las filas del gobierno uno de
ellos El embajador de Argentina en
Brasil y ex candidato presidencial
Daniel scioli quien mantuvo hasta la
última hora su aspiración el partido les
agradeció reconocemos a los compañeros
Eduardo de Pedro y Daniel scioli que
apostaron a la unidad del peronismo
anteponiendo lo colectivo por sobre lo
individual a pesar del nombramiento
sorpresivo massa Era uno de los nombres
que manejaba la opinión pública Aunque
su administración como ministro de
economía No grangió mucho apoyo con 51
años Sergio massa fue la última carta
del gobierno de Alberto Fernández para
hacer flotar a un país gravemente
afectado por deudas e inflación